hey here's something really interesting
we've been getting calls from a guy who
just calls and and basically leaves
religious doctrine on our voicemail
number and we played a voicemail from
him earlier in the week and we got
another voicemail from him and a number
of people in the audience believe that
they've identified this guy let's take a
listen to his latest voicemail first and
then I'll tell you who people in the
audience think that this is I David it's
me again I wanted to add a couple things
yeah I wanted to say that I believe
Jesus was or is helping me out in my
life because I've had a horrible
horrible life in existence he's for 54
years
yeah and that I don't know how many
times I've almost lost my life and
almost getting an accident or or you
know just things happening and somebody
has gotten me through that okay so
anyway this guy's been calling in
leaving these messages a bunch of people
started emailing me saying David that
sounds like religious youtuber Brett
Keane who you're familiar with
wright-patt you're you've heard of this
oh yeah he was the chief antagonist on
the drunken peasants which is a show
that's now defunct yes you're familiar
with that show you know the show I've
been on it I'm not familiar with this
guy so I went to his YouTube channel
there's definitely a similarity and I'm
gonna play it for you let's take a
listen to this guy who some in the
audience claim is the religious caller
hello ladies and gentlemen my name is
Brett King from god TV radio calm today
I thought I'd talk about my first
experience was seeing someone die yeah
now the voice is very similar the
delivery is similar but you've said Pat
that he's not the caller said he's 54
years old
you didn't think Brett Kane was 54 right
but that looks 54 to me that guy that
you just played a video of he doesn't
look older than he is but he's
apparently only like 40 41 42 you're
telling me that the guy you just showed
me video of is 40 years old I know
hard to believe David that there's no
way can you put up a still just like
pause the video and put that up so I can
get another look and the audience can
see it as well you're telling me that
that's a 40 year old that guy is only
seven years older than me I I'm telling
you this yes that he's running to the
drunken peasants community - yeah I mean
I'm not alone here
all right well listen I don't know if
it's Brett keen who's calling but
interesting and I'm glad that the
audience has gotten involved we've got a
great bonus show for you today we'll
talk about right-wing Twitter bashing
Lester Holt we will talk about an iPhone
battery bursting into flame after a man
bit his battery why did he do that well
we'll talk about it on the bonus show
and we will talk about a letter which
suggests that three Alcatraz inmates
survive their 1962 escape and swam to
land I actually have visited Alcatraz
several times and unfamiliar with the
story and I have some thoughts david
pakman.com slash membership patreon.com
slash david pakman show we will speak to
you then